yeah so you're involved in avid life
media sorry
um you told a a few stories to us um
around your time there uh what did
avidlife media
manage what was that dating site all
about yeah i mean i i don't openly talk
about that right now so i'll speak
vaguely about it um but um you know we
we operated a bunch of dating sites
often in various
uh unique uh niches or or uh
um particular communities
and uh you know they were very
successful
at creating awareness uh through taking
cheeky approaches
to to marketing and pr uh and
recognizing that there are
opportunities um to do things that would
create a pr opportunity
um far greater than the advertising so
one time we
offered to um you know wrap
a street car in a banner um
around the streetcar uh for one of our
sites and
uh we knew that initially they'd
probably get rejected but to our
surprise
uh they actually said yes and so we
looked at it and we said
well we could either pay the 25 000 or
whatever it was to
wrap the streetcar in in this particular
advertisement
or we could leak it to the media because
that would be just juicy enough for the
media to say like hey this company is
now wrapping a streetcar is the ttc
actually okay with it and get
much more awareness and publicity uh for
free than paying the 25
000 or you know one time we uh
where we were there was a well-known
actor
uh who had voiced advertisements that
most of you probably heard of this is
probably
10 or 11 years ago um but it turned out
the the actual ad you heard was
this particular actor's voice but what
happened is the company who was making
the ad
had initially approached this actor who
wanted some obscene amount of money just
to audition for the part
um and so that company decided to be
like
okay well we'll find someone who sounds
like you and and record the ad anyway
because we don't want to pay just to
have you
audition um and so they prepared the ad
with this
sound alike's voice and and sort of
submitted it to the actor and said
listen you can do it or we're going to
go forward with this and
the actor said okay i'll do it and it
came to a much more reasonable approach
we subsequently found out about it uh
and so
in the same kind of concept context the
same kind of mindset
we got the sound alike we recorded an ad
you know started playing it on the
on the radio in the us knowing that the
following would happen
people would start saying like hey is
this actor doing
an ad for this particular dating site
which would probably be shocking some of
most people's sensibilities
and we did and there's a whole bunch of
pr that followed and then
inevitably we're expecting a letter from
his lawyers which we got saying hey
you're inappropriately using this
actor's persona please stop and so we
did
you know and we got millions of dollars
worth of free publicity and pr
uh with no consequence because we knew
the lawyer the letter would come
we would stop and then it just doesn't
make sense for people to litigate beyond
that
um because it's too expensive there's no
guarantees and litigation and
and so it was uh it was a great cheeky
opportunity to create some awareness now
it you know with hindsight at the time
it seemed like a great idea in hindsight
you know i've kind of come to the place
where it's probably not
fair or appropriate to use someone's
identity in that way to
benefit yourself um but these are just
examples of things you can do
to you know push boundaries or another
good example is we would always offer to
sponsor
you know uh major events you know and
then
uh we would get rejected um or we would
just leak the fact that we're putting in
an offer to
to sponsor a major event um to the media
and then you'd see it in the news the
next day that this dating site is uh
offering to sponsor the the super bowl
or the world cup or whatever it was
um and again knowing that we were taking
risks we were wading into regulatory
gray zones but
there was really no consequences that
would come back to bite us at any point
so we took advantage of those
opportunities
you